وصل الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن مساء
الاثنين الى ورسو زياره يترقبها الكثير من
البولنديين واللاجئين الاوكرانيين في
بولندا
من تغيير الوضع المشكله ان بوتين لا يخاف
من اي شيء
او من اي شخص
ان يزيد الامريكيون من شحنات الاسلحه
المرسله لنا
امل ان يعلن عن المزيد من المساعدات لاننا
لا نملك اسلحه كافيه
زياده المساعدات الامريكيه وتسليم معدات
جديده هذا بالضبط ما وعد به جو بايدن خلال
زيارته المفاجئه الى كييف يوم الاثنين
مؤكدا الدعم الثابت للولايات المتحده
لحليفتها الاوكرانيه
يلتقي جو بايدن في وورسو بالرئيس البولندي
اندري دوده يوم الثلاثاء حيث تعتبر بولندا
احد الداعمين الاوروبيين الاساسيين
لاوكرانيا
ياتي خطاب بايدن كرد على خطاب نظيره
الروسي فلاديمير بوتين في موسكو صباح
الثلاثاء مبارزه خطابيه تعبر عن وجهتين
نظر متعارضتين جذريا بشان غزو روسيا
لاوكرانيا